c'est le grand favori de cette élection
présidentielle en equateur andres arrose
candidat socialiste est en tête des
sondages avec 32% des intentions de vote
arrivé sur le devant de la scène
politique récemment le jeune économiste
était méconnu du grand public il y a
encore six mois
le candidat de la coalition union pour
l'espérance est soutenu par l'ancien
chef de l'état rafael correa
ce qui explique en grande partie sa
popularité son objectif rompre avec la
politique du gouvernement du président
lenin moreno à quito où il a terminé sa
campagne entouré de ses nombreux
soutiens
il a promis un scrutin en un seul tour
et une grande victoire populaire pour la
vie pour la dignité
c'est pour cela que nous sommes ici et
c'est pour cela que nous allons
remporter une grande victoire populaire
ce dimanche 7 février
parmi les 16 candidats à la présidence
deux autres figures se démarque lié
remet au lasso ex-banquier représentants
de la droite conservatrice se présente
pour la troisième fois à la magistrature
suprême
il prône une démocratie totale et un
équateur d'opportunités à la fois je
serai avec ma famille chez moi plein de
paix en attendant les résultats
ils vont être positif ils le seront
certainement le peuple équatorien on a
assez des quatorze ans de socialisme au
21ème siècle dernières figures qui s'est
démarqué de cette campagne
présidentielle yakou perez voir tant
belle militants écologistes incarne la
défense des droits des indigènes avec
son parti de gauche pachakutik avocats
de 51 ans fervent militant des droits
humains
il combat depuis toujours la politique
d'austérité du gouvernement actuel je
suis toujours en militant et je vais le
rester
c'est dans mes gènes je porte ce là dans
mon coeur mais aujourd'hui la préfecture
provincial est pour moi un instrument un
outil pour défendre mon peuple pour
qu'il échappe à l'état colonial et
hiérarchique qui impose ses décisions
le pays s'apprête à élire son nouveau
président dans un contexte d'endettement
et de crise financière aggravée par la
pandémie de coronavirus guillermo olaso
et yacou perez récoltent respectivement
21 % et 10 % des intentions de vote
pour l'emporter dès le premier tour en
grèce a rose devra obtenir au moins 40 %
des voix un scénario peu probable pour
les analystes ce qui entraînerait la
tenue d'un second tour le 11 avril
prochain